jesse's with us in arizona good
afternoon how can dr d and i help
all right gentlemen how you guys doing
today doing well man how can we help
all right uh this uh this question is
more uh
for dr john baloney in a relationship
aspect
um currently um let me just start out by
saying i'm madly in love with this woman
i was doing something
i wouldn't do jesse any time somebody
jesse
anytime somebody starts out with that
sentence i know we're gonna have some
this is going to be interesting no no no
well maybe a little bit but
because she is probably listening to
this um
so the problem we're having right now is
she comes home every day from her
job her job and she's unhappy
she's crying she calls me you know two
three times a day because
we just talk to each other a lot
throughout the day and and it's always
complaints about her job she wants to
get out and she hates it
she she hates her job i don't like the
word hate but she hates her job okay
um she has a cosmetology
she is a certified cosmetologist and
that is her passion
and she loves it okay but the problem
we're running
into is she doesn't want to just work at
some
you know average place where she's a
cosmetologist she wants to
do hair she wants to be in her own
studio and make good money
well right now she's in a secure job or
gives her a secure paycheck
um our incomes differ
by about double so i make about double
what she does okay
i told her i have your back yep
no matter what i just want to get you
out of this j-o-b
and get you into your career now we've
we've been on and off for about 20 years
so this isn't a new relationship no
we're not married we're gonna get
married okay
but we need our relationship more secure
in order to do that
i need her to be secure at her job
at her career so i want to get her out
of the insurance what she's doing right
now because she does like uh write
checks and stuff for a big insurance
company and i want her
to get her into cosmetology her being
happy
and we've we've thought of other plans
on how to do it but
she she doesn't really she doesn't
really trust me
per se um when it comes to having her
back she's always been a single mom
with two boys she's always been the
provider the
alpha male of the house now i step in
you know and
and yeah i know the kids and i know her
but
she's still used to being the major
breadwinner the person who
always has to be there for the boys yeah
and i get it she's a mom like
i wouldn't want her to be any other way
like your kids first
but how do i get her to trust me
to to allow me to take over some of the
finances in the house
so she can pursue her career and get out
of this job
man um you're not gonna like my answers
how direct you are how direct do you
want me to be
you know what hey i'm on dave's show i'm
gonna be real direct
i'm gonna take it from old man here
number one
if you've known her for 20 years and she
doesn't trust you
there's a reason yep number two
you can't make her do anything yep and
the fact that you're trying to make her
do something is only
making her not trust you more well okay
this is the thing doctor is
she this is something that she wants to
do as well hey honey
hey jesse jesse jesse yeah she's raised
two boys
yeah she can do anything
oh i know she can say she wants to
change but she doesn't because if she
did
she would okay yeah and so
what you have to do is be
in love with the person she is not the
person you think you can mold and create
for her
yeah no i'm totally in love with her the
way she is i like i wouldn't want her
any other way hey but
what job she's then but listen brother
what you told me is
when she can finally deal with this
relation i mean with her job stuff then
finally
then finally i can marry her and what
you're telling her is
when you become the person that i want
you to be
then you'll be good enough for me not
till then
and so you've got your relationship
though absolutely
i wrote down on my paper while you were
talking
your relationship math is off if you
worked for amazon they'd fire you
because you cannot make an algorithm
your a plus b good thing i don't work
out that's right
hey listen you are you
have walked into a situation where you
want to be the savior of it i love your
heart man i see what
you see somebody that you care about i
just want to support her that's right
i don't want to give her i don't want to
give her alternatives i don't want to
give her choices i want her
to make those choices i just want her to
trust me that i'll have her back
that's right so when it comes to like an
electric bill comes in
and she needs you know she doesn't have
it sam dave i can pay just ask me and
i'll pay
that's right listen listen listen it's
it's
your heart is good okay your heart is
good here yeah you've got to sit down
with her
not about not about what your job's
going to be give me a solution not about
hey i've got your back financially
but you guys have 20 years of stuff
y'all got to work through
there's a reason she doesn't trust you
to pick up i trust
anthony i met anthony a year ago and i
trust him that if i needed
if i called him and said hey bro i'm
about to cut my lights off you know what
i mean so there's something there
a 20-year arc of your relationship that
there's no trust there the second thing
is
you got to decide am i going to marry
this person for who she is
even if she's in a tough job or
am i going to be out because the way
you've written this out for yourself
you've provided yourself with a wife
when she does what you want her to do
and i know that's not your heart so i
didn't feel like that's what you've done
but it is and if she's listening to this
rewind it and say are those guys crazy
and she'll probably get a tear in her
eye and say no
and then maybe that's gonna be the
avenue for a hard conversation anthony i
can feel you next to me pulsing man
i'll probably get in trouble like i did
yesterday so i think i should just
go for it not say what i really want to
say say what you're going to say man
say what you're going to say again i
mean let me say let me set this up like
this
uh this is not dave ramsey's opinion
this is not dr john deloney's opinion
this is anthony o'neill's opinion i'm
scooting over in case you get struck by
life
if my friend came home to me and said
i'm still dating this guy after 20 years
i'm telling her to leave
hmm that's just bottom line i'm just i'm
i'm not dealing with some i don't know
by the way that's my opinion too yeah
that's your opinion thank you yes
give me some love yeah because i felt i
felt like 20 years
there's a reason why she doesn't trust
you and it's not just all on her there's
something inside of you
the man that is not allowing her to open
up now again i'm not a relationship
expert this is your lane i'm just saying
if my cousin if my sister if my
friend came to me i'm saying baby girl
move on i mean
if a man don't have your heart after a
year two years that ain't the one
well if if it's about
achievement right it's about when you do
these things then i'm gonna be able to
love you
and that's a hard recipe after 20 years